it's been good to have a break honestly
from the craziness of American politics
for a few days I completely checked out
over the Thanksgiving break here in the
United States one of the very clear
things that happened while we were gone
is that Donald Trump has started to do
just a really good job as president of
the United States just kidding I hope
you didn't tone out I'm kidding about
that what happened is that the legal
noose is sort of starting to tighten
around Rudy Giuliani it was pretty clear
really more than a year ago that the
former New York City Mayor was trouble
for Trump he got pulled off TV
appearances for a while he is now back
front and center because of his
involvement in the Ukraine Fiasco and
now it really could be a tragic end for
Rudy Giuliani in the Greek tragedy sense
I used that term up for Donald Trump's
maybe personal lawyer I guess at this
point we don't really know what the
relationship is between Rudy and Trump
two of Rudy's associates have been
arrested left Parnas and Egor Froman one
of them left Parnas is cooperating and
says as I told you early last week that
he can directly and specifically
implicate Republican congressman Devin
Nunez in the Ukraine Fiasco we may have
more news about that later this week a
grand jury has now issued a subpoena for
documents related to rudy giuliani's
international consulting as he calls it
which is one of those innocuous terms
international consulting I call it
influence pet peddling and negotiating
bribery and smears and that relates to a
whole bunch of possible crimes that Rudy
may have committed we're looking at
money laundering wire fraud campaign
finance violations making false
statements obstruction of justice
violations of the foreign agents
Registration Act fara
as it's known we're talking here about
both criminal and congressional
investigations into Rudy Giuliani's work
and the things that he's done and Rudy
of course denies everything always
telling TMZ TMZ found him at an airport
I think over the Thanksgiving break and
he said oh there's no way that I'm going
to end up in prison but remember Roger
stone told me the same thing when I
interviewed him about a year and a half
ago he was of course recently found
guilty on seven counts
we'll be sentenced in a couple of months
heading to prison potentially up to 20
years
realistically much much less what this
increasingly is going to be about so to
set the stage for you for the next month
year few years I don't really know how
long this is going to go what is going
to determine the future for Rudy
Giuliani is whether Trump abandons him
or sticks with him because that's the
trend as we've already seen happen
sometimes people throw Trump under the
bus and then Trump abandons them Michael
Cohen is one example but maybe that's
not exactly the way it happened maybe
it's more that Trump makes it clear he's
not going to stand by the person and
then they throw Trump under the bus but
the point is you have the on the one
hands people like Michael Cohen on the
other hand you've got the people like
Paul Manafort
and Roger stone who have at least
seemingly remained loyal to Donald Trump
during their prosecutions and it's still
plausible that a pardon is coming for
them we don't know yet but it is
certainly plausible the real factor that
will determine Rudy Giuliani's future is
not did he break the law or didn't he
did he act immorally or didn't he did he
do this or did he do that Rudy is
privileged such that he is not part of
the justice system for the most of us
he's part of a different justice system
where it's who your friends are whether
it's does the president remain loyal to
you that is what will determine the
future for Rudy Giuliani he has a
get-out-of-jail-free card not in a
proverbial sense in a literal sense it's
called a presidential pardon on
corporate media they're staging these
dumb little debates about Oh does Rudy
risk having his reputation tarnished by
this scandal first of all that assumes
that Rudy had a good reputation before
this forget about that for now that's a
debate for a different day Rudy Giuliani
has become a sort of villain of the
worst intersection of influence-peddling
vulture capitalism and international
corruption and has made it clear that
what his values are are unquenchable
thirst for proximity to power money he
will use any a so
see Asians at all to further those goals
it doesn't matter what it means for the
United States as a country and that's
how you end up in a position to have to
day in and day out on national media
defend the indefensible which are the
actions of Donald Trump the next couple
of weeks particularly with the upcoming
impeachment hearings there are more
starting Wednesday we'll be covering
them live on YouTube they will be
illuminating I predict about Rudy
Giuliani's role and we'll catch up about
it later this week or early next when we
actually get to see what is said at this
week's impeachment hearings the holidays
are almost here this means you might be
looking for some gifts for other people
maybe for yourself that's okay too
and a great idea for a gift is a stylish
shirt that actually fits correctly
because unlike most brands untucked
shirts are designed to be worn untucked
they always fall at the just right
length I'm wearing an untucked shirt
right now I've got a bunch of them there
are more than 50 fit combinations and
they look great whether you're tall
shorts slim athletic whatever you can
choose from styles like wrinkle free
button downs super soft flannels
outerwear and more you can find your
favorite untuck it style online or check
out one of their 80 brick-and-mortar
stores so whether you're shopping for
the perfect holiday gift maybe you want
a relaxed smart style of your own untuck
it is the way to go visit untuck it calm
and use code Pakman for 20% off at
checkout that's un tu CK IT dot-com
promo code Pakman for 20% off